oh
mo
on varie d formidable
bosseur au sérieux
je m'appelle frontenac h mon métier
c'est menuisier entre guillemets je
fabrique des meubles en bois de palettes
oui je vais vous montrer ma première
réalisation qui est pas très joli à mon
goût mais qui me qui voilà qui maquille
mal et d'autres d'autres meubles par la
suite qui m'a permis de montrer ce que
je savais faire
ça va plus ça m'a amusé donc je me suis
dit allez pourquoi pas j'ai travaillé
dans le bâtiment tant qu'électricien et
puis j'ai eu une fin de contrat donc je
me suis retrouvé au chômage pendant
quelques mois et pendant ces mois je me
suis je suis j'ai toujours été très
entrepreneur dans l'âme
donc je me suis mis à chercher une une
activité qui me corresponde avec la
conjoncture actuelle on se dit est ce
que ça va il faut que ça marche tout de
suite
est-ce que ça va tenir est ce qu'on va y
arriver est ce que mais j'ai confiance
donc ya pas de raison parce que c'est
cette une à la base c'est une très bonne
idée c'est un marché qui est à prendre
parce qu'ils ne sont pas nombreux
donc
il n'y a pas de raison que ça ne marche
pas
menu petite société quinze palettes
c'est ça c'est ça mon atelier là c'est
tout récent de la société les tout
jeunes à la st croix
le thé très très artisanal des fabriqués
maison tablit stocks
mais voilà toutes les petites
réalisations en cours c'est pas ce qui
se fait de mieux au niveau confort c'est
sûr qui fait assez chaud là dedans mais
je suis à l'abri
moi j'aime ce genre de défi ça marche
c'est bien ça marche pas tant pis
j'aurais essayé mais c'est vrai que
c'est un métier nouveau gelé constater
quand j'ai quand j'ai eu besoin d'une
assurance 1 où je rentrais dans aucune
case monsieur c'est stéphane acket
stéphane kim chi qui est mon voisin qui
fait la même chose
l'entreprise tout en palettes on a les
deux entreprises différentes m'ont fait
la même chose juste à côté voilà on
n'était peut-être pas tout à fait chaud
au départ parce qu on est quand même
concurrent mais comme on s'entend bien
et que qu'on a qu'on a vite compris que
d'être complémentaire serait une très
bonne chose
eh ben on avance dans ce sens là
si on fait ça c'est pas pour monter un
meuble pour une personne et puis dire on
arrête machin ce qui a vraiment une
continuité l'avantagent de la palette en
fin de compte 6 est perpétuellement
modulable et c'est perpétuellement
attachant pâques en fête
ce loi a sa petite histoire ou qu'on ne
connaît pas mais qu'on peut imaginer
qu'il a été peut-être partout dans le
monde
il s'est retrouvé peut-être chez
quelqu'un dans un pays à l'autre bout du
monde puis aujourd'hui il à la réunion
or voilà le mot qui a été réalisé pour
le petit coin ferait un comptoir accueil
caisse vitrine
c'est un côté unique en fait donc c'est
un côté où on ne pourra pas trouver ce
meuble votre part que tu peu après
justement non du tout du tout du tout
pour moi c'est du bois et le recyclage
adore donc je suis contre le gaspillage
donc si ça peut utiliser ça peut être
utile encore le bois pourquoi pas faire
des meubles avec quoi cette motivation
qu'on a quand on travaille pour soi
c'est ça n'a rien à voir
alors lorsqu'on est employé qu'on a
c'est on peut faire des heures beaucoup
d'heures sans les voir passer avec des
bonds à tous avec des bonnes z
ouais je pense qu'il ya de jolis sur la
faire entendre que son entreprise
grandit ce qu'ils puissent ensuite après
avoir des collaborateurs des employés
pour qu'ils puissent former et
après lâché un petit peu v s'occuper de
sa famille mais bon ça c'est comme pour
tout le monde à 1 quand on démarre on
est toujours au bas de l'échelle et au
petit à petit on monte y'a pas de raison
pour que ça marche pas moi je suis
confiante et puis réaliser quelque chose
de ses mains moi c'est ce que j'aime et
quand c'est terminé c'est voilages
ensuite j'en suis fier